so you rated the bleach the same as my
hero season one would you
still stand by that yeah i would because
like look
again as much as i don't think my hero
is like the second coming of christ
season one was solid as [ __ ] like i
enjoyed it i i would i would say
for me my hero it goes season two
than season one than season three right
right we haven't had season four yet
have we
i don't even know wait no no no no no we
haven't i don't think so i wouldn't no
we have no
academia season four the most
mainstream anime point is the biggest
three areas
i don't know if there's a next season of
my hero so the next one's announced but
i i saw on twitter everyone's like the
next dark is boring and i was like
great so just another year of just
mediocre [ __ ] showing
yeah even the biggest even the biggest
shonen right now it's just like yeah
whatever
no i mean like the thing is with my hero
is that i started off really really
liking it and i
and to me to me like out of all the
modern shonen it had the potential to be
the greatest right like like he had the
potential to reach like a higher ceiling
than say something like say black clover
yeah or demon slayer or something like
that but it seems like
the setup is there and the potential is
there but there just hasn't been that
moment for me to really
make me love this and the it seems like
the more
the more i watch just the less and less
invest i get in there well that's how i
kind of felt watching season one like
you know the first half of season one to
me was like okay
i like this premise like superheroes
quirks okay cool yeah i can see why
people are into this
and it's good [ __ ] like action scenes
were pretty [ __ ] sold characters
pretty [ __ ] solid but then the
further along i got i was just like
yeah all right all right yeah it's just
it's just a showing
it's just good it's just it's just good
it's it's acceptable it's it's like i i
struggle
to find words just to describe how i
feel towards it because i'm just like
at the beginning i'm just like yeah i've
really liked this i'm really hyped for
this and the more i watch the more i'm
just like
yeah it's good yeah there's not really
much to say about it that's all it is
it's just good good it's good it's
adequate it's like going to a cousin's
birthday party
just like yeah i'll go i'll go but like
you know i'm not that thrilled about it
yeah but i'll turn up yeah you know
be supportive how was your cousin's
birthday it was it was good yeah it was
[ __ ] good
yeah yeah yeah that's that's how i feel
that's how the show is that's it
exactly but but that's the thing like
people make it out to be because i'm not
you know praising the [ __ ] out of it
publicly
people immediately think oh joey hates
my hair academia i don't hate my
academia i just think it's fine i just
you know i just like yeah i just cry
every time deku talks man
yeah i'm not a fan of deku either um i
don't understand why people love bakugo
so much i feel like is there something
like gone wrong in the childhood of
girls who are like really into him to me
it's like he's just kind of an [ __ ] i
understand okay i understand why people
love todoroki like that is that is like
set up to be like yeah fan favorite yeah
yeah yeah why bakugou is people's
favorites i don't understand
it's i i it's like the worst kid in
school everyone's like i love this kid
it's like it's like it's like people
like we're talking about bleach it's
like back in bleach days when people
said that renji was their favorite i'm
like
what he's just an angry kid because
they're like no he's a nice guy secretly
and i'm like have you ever met someone
who's an [ __ ] in real life he's
secretly not
the [ __ ] world what's what's what's
weird to me right it's like you know the
same kind of twitter accounts and the
same kind of fan base i see like
defending barco and having
him as their favorite character is like
the same kind of
accounts that i see [ __ ] trying to
cancel people for like
10 year old tweets or something like
that and i'm like here
they're trying to cancel people for that
and here they are being like oh i mean
bucko like was a bully back in back in
like middle school whatever
but he's like turned around now he's a
good guy now friends to support him now
so it's a lot easier to get behind a
fictional character's turnaround story
yeah exactly
they're a real person right like those
people were defending
vegeta and he's talking he [ __ ] tried
to blow up the planet two arcs ago man
jesus [ __ ] christ all right he's a
good guy now